yeah I think Evolution just in itself is
an emerging property that we're
describing so yeah it's just multiple
different interactions that we're trying
to explain
and we can never
really we can only ever grasp it at a
higher level and that's it it's a kind
of search process which accumulates
information yeah and unlike almost every
other search process that we've created
in computers it never converges it's
just still emerging just continuously
accumulating information it's an
agent isn't
it well simply that they've become more
and more complex with time right
and intelligence has existed from the
GetGo um as soon as like as soon as a
single agent exists intelligence exists
and so the evolution of it is simply a
byproduct of multiple agents then
existing and multiple different types of
Agents existing